بالضربات الصاروخيه التي تستهدف البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه يحاول الروس تحريك وتدل
استقرار في الدوله الاوكرانيه واجبار
الاوكرانيين على تقديم التنازلات خاصه مع
قدوم فصل الشتاء وانخفاض درجه الحراره الى
ما تحت الصفر وتساقطي الثلوج
الكهرباء او انبوب الغاز هذا لن يشكل ازمه
بالنسبه لنا
لا توجد كهرباء لكن صامدون نحن اوكرانيون
وسنصمد
بشكل
اسره تعيش دون كهرباء والدوله عاجزه في ظل
الهجمات المتلاحقه على منشات الطاقه عن
ترميم النظام الذي عجز عن توليد القدر
الكافي استهلاكي مع دعا شركه الكهرباء الى
مضاعفه الانقطاعات لا سيما في العاصمه كيف
اسقدوا انهم سيكسرون ناب
لسي الكراهيه تجاهها جميع الرؤوس على هذا
الكوكب
الاهم اولا ان لا نفقد الامل وان نرفع
معنوياتنا وهناك سبل كثيره للتعامل مع
الامر نغادر المنزل ونذهب الى الاصدقاء
والاهل هناك كثير من الحلول للخروج من
الازمه وهذا لن يكسرنا ولا شيء سيكسروا
عزيمتنا على الرغم من جلد الاوكرانيين
وصمودهم الا ان الاثر واضح في توقف
الاعمال بالساعه بسبب انقطاع التيار ما
يزيد من خسائر اصحاب الاعمال والدوله
الامر الذي ينعكس على مداخل المواطنين كما
ترتفع الاسعار نسبه لارتفاع سعر التكلفه
اضافه الى البرد القارس الذي يهدد حياه
الاوكرانيه